RICH FULCHER: Good morning.
Thank you all for
joining us today.
We'll just start with a couple
of introductions and then dive
right into the material.
So I'm Rich Fulcher.
DAVE CHIU: I'm Dave Chiu.
ZACH GIBSON: Zach Gibson.
BETHANY FONG: And
I'm Bethany Fong.
RICH FULCHER: And
we're all designers
working from across Google,
from Android to Chrome,
concentrating on bringing
Material Design to Google's
apps.
And just personally,
we're really
thrilled to be here this
morning to really get
to show off this work
that we've been working on
for quite a while now.
So thanks for coming.
Yesterday's keynote
introduced Material Design,
which is a new visual
language focused
on creating bold,
graphic interfaces.
It takes the principles of
typography, position, scale,
and color, and
uses those to build
really wonderful interfaces.
Material Design combines these
classic print design principles
with the kind of
innovation that you
can achieve through the
application of technology.
It takes elements that were
formerly static and makes
them reactive and responsive.
It receives energy from the
user, from the user's finger,
from their mouse click,
and it directs that energy
to power transformation
and animation
of the material itself.
Material Design is also
one adaptive design.
So it's a single
design system that
covers handheld and web devices.
It covers a variety of
different form factors.
Now, this is important
because it enables the user
to leverage the mastery
they gain in one context
and apply it to another to get
that sense of intuitiveness
that comes from being
able to do that.
In this session,
we're going to discuss
how Material Design
affects the way you design
the interaction of
your applications.
We're going to cover
three major topics today.
We're going to start by talking
about the materials themselves
and the properties
of those materials
that guide how you use them.
That will lead into a
discussion of structure, which
will cover both the level
of how do I structure
individual scenes or views
within my application,
and then up to how do I
structure my entire app.
And finally, we'll
end by looking
at some of the standard
components that
are kind of novel
for Material Design
and go into a bit of detail
about how you can apply them
that are particularly important.
So since Material
is the metaphor that
powers this entire system,
let's start by talking about two
of the fundamental
ones-- paper and ink.
DAVE CHIU: In Material Design,
every pixel drawn by an app
is a dot of ink on
a piece of paper.
Paper is, on its own, colorless.
Ink can be any color.
Each piece of paper wants to
be a simple shape with rounded
corners-- a rectangle, a
square, or a circle, which
is, after all, just a square
with extremely rounded corners.
Paper does not want to
be a star or a triangle
or the shape of your app icon.
Ink is much less restricted.
It can flow into any shape.
Measured in the x- and
y-axes, both paper and ink
can have any size.
Paper can fill the
entire display such
that you can't see
the edges, or it
can be the size of
a single button.
The size of ink is limited only
by its need to stay on paper.
But paper has an
absolute fixed thickness
equal to one DIP, or
Density Independent Pixel.
Now, why is that important?
Because we must now consider the
z-axis when laying out content.
As a quick refresher, the z-axis
is perpendicular to both the x-
and y-axes, allowing us to
position surfaces in front
of or behind other surfaces.
Paper surfaces are
intuitive and natural.
But to maintain that
materiality, we layer
and move them in ways
that could plausibly
fit within these devices.
This means we constrain
paper's behavior
based on the perceived
z depth of the device.
So for a phone,
that's the distance
between your thumb on
the screen to the back
of the phone against
the palm of your hand.
Monitors and television
support perceived
z depth greater than their
physical dimensions in part
because we don't physically
handle the devices.
The position of a piece
of paper gives the user
hints about how it
relates to other paper.
The dimensionality
invites interaction.
When the user sees
a realistic shadow,
they think there is a gap-- we
call it a step-- between two
pieces of paper, and they will
behave and move independently.
When there is no shadow between
two coplanar pieces of paper,
the edge they share
is instead a seam.
And the movement of
those pieces of paper
will be linked together.
Paper always occupies
a single z position.
It is always flat, never
tilted so that one edge is
closer than another to
the user, and it does not
flip over to show
the other side.
The z position of paper
is also a reflection
of content hierarchy.
Paper with a z position
closer to the user
typically contains content
you want the user to focus on,
such as a dialog
box, or when you
select a date in the
calendar and it expands
and moves forward from the grid.
Paper with a z
position that's higher
also tends to affect
underlying content.
An obvious example is
a navigation drawer,
which appears above
everything else
because it changes
the displayed content.
App bars are another
obvious example.
With Material
Design, rather than
thinking of depth as
ornament-- so adding a few drop
shadows here and there
and calling it a day--
use depth to help users
understand how your app works,
how content is organized,
and the scope of actions.
So let's talk about layout.
How do we take all the
possibilities of this system
and present them in a coherent
and consistent fashion?
ZACH GIBSON: In all of our
Material Design layouts,
we strive for consistency,
a cohesive experience
across all of our apps.
This starts with the
fundamental structure
of how we build our
applications and layouts.
The history of graphic
design has given us
tools like key lines,
baseline grids, aspect ratios,
and the use of incremental
spatial relationships
in our designs.
These tools are the
building blocks that we use
and we need to create
consistency in our designs
across mobile
tablet and desktop.
Historically, the best
graphic design work
has come from a deep
understanding of a grid
structure, so that when it's
used to its full potential
or even when something
breaks this grid structure,
it can be done in exciting and
innovative and delightful ways.
So there's a visual design talk
that's happening later today.
And it's going to cover a bit
more details about the grid
structure.
But for this
presentation, it's just
important to note that
our grid system is
based on an 8-DIP increment.
So it's nothing new, really.
If you've been
working for the web,
these are very familiar
and friendly numbers.
You'll find that our headers,
icons, paper elements, padding,
margins, buttons, et cetera are
all numbers like 16, 24, 32,
96, 960, 1,024.
You get the idea.
They're all familiar and
friendly numbers to us.
We're just baking
this into the system
for the sake of consistency
and visual harmony across all
of our screens.
So with our grid now
in place, I think
we're ready to start
designing some apps.
RICH FULCHER: OK, so how do
the properties of paper and ink
affect the way that you
actually structure your app?
So when you construct
any particular screen,
we've found it best
to start from paper.
That's the material
that's really
going to define the
architecture of any scene
or view that you're
going to construct.
And it's going to
call out what elements
are surfaced above or below
or can move independently.
You can always come back and do
ink as kind of a second pass.
You've got your paper laid out.
Then you can fill in as you
would just kind of draw it in,
all of the controls, all of
the content, as a later action.
We've spent a lot
of time actually
cutting out pieces of paper and
layering them and moving them
till we came up,
within the system,
with views that made sense.
I really got to hone
my scissor and glue
skills working on this project.
We even used things
like little wooden discs
here to track the Floating
Action Button, which
is a highlight component
within Material Design
that Bethany will
go into more detail
about in just a
couple of minutes.
So playing with paper
is a great practice
for just getting a sense of
how this design system works.
It really gives
you a feel for how
the surfaces will
interact with each other.
When they approach
each other, does one
lift to get out of
the way of the other?
Do they move
together as a group?
And just kind of shuffling
the paper around physically
helps you just very quickly
get an understanding of that.
It's a really fast,
really cheap, even kind
of fun way of designing.
So when we're talking about just
the structural possibilities
for your app at the high
level, all of the possibilities
that you're used to
seeing are still there.
If your app wants to
use tabs, that's great.
We support that.
No worries.
If you occasionally indulge in
using a left side navigation
drawer, that's covered, too.
That pattern's there.
If your app is all about
search, we like search, too.
That's a pattern that
you can support, as well.
As a designer or developer
of your application,
you are responsible for picking
the most appropriate pattern
that's going to best serve
your users and their goals.
So be sure to consider
all the possibilities.
Now, each of those
will have its own set
of advantages and disadvantages.
I'll pick on the left navigation
drawer for just a moment here.
This is a really
suitable pattern
if you have a large number
of high-level views.
It becomes, effectively,
this very convenient table
of contents to your application
that the user can quickly
access and scan and
jump to a section.
It can also be really valuable
if your app has deep paths
through its hierarchy,
where the user can go down,
down, down to deeper
levels, because they
can use the drawer
as a rapid mechanism
for pivoting back and going
to a different top level
without having to go up,
up, up first to do that.
On the other hand, there
are drawbacks to the drawer.
It's clearly not as
obvious as something
like tabs, which are immediately
visible on the screen all
of the time.
It also may not be ideal if
the contents of the drawer
are heterogeneous, if it's not
a standard list of categories
or labels, because,
in that case,
the user is going to need
to spend a little bit more
time using your app to
familiarize themselves
with what the content
of that drawer
is, because they're not
seeing it all of the time.
On the other other hand,
that could be valuable
if you're trying to demote
some of that content,
if those are less frequently
visited destinations
that you want to politely
steer the user away from,
but make accessible
in certain situations.
So as every designer
always says, it depends.
ZACH GIBSON: So the
previous examples
that Rich showed and a lot
of the screens that we've
been looking at are all mobile.
But the basic structure
of our applications
applies to mobile tablet
and desktop layouts.
The tools that we have at
our disposal are all here.
There's an app bar, there's
a canvas area with a Floating
Action Button, there's an
occasional bottom bar and side
navs that can be
accessed temporarily.
From a structural standpoint,
we keep this stuff
around no matter what
the screen size is.
So as we move up in
the tablet, the app bar
can absorb elements
that couldn't
fit into the mobile screens,
and the side nav bars can still
be accessed temporarily
as they were in mobile,
or they can be pinned.
Additionally, in our
desktop structure,
the side nav bar as well
as content canvas area
can have secondary
toolbars for things
like tabs or palettes or
just secondary actions.
As you'll notice
in Material Design,
these structural elements
are all extremely flexible.
They can move and
react to screen sizes
and different contexts
in magical ways.
So let's take a look at
some of the family shots
that we have to see
what's happening.
In this example
of a file browser,
you can see a lot of the stuff
that we talked about in action.
The header is extended based
on a default height of the app
bar.
And this is really
just to create
a little bit of visual
hierarchy in the layout
for the tiles and the list.
As you can see on the
desktop screen here,
the right nav is
pinned while browsing.
In the mobile screen here, we
add intentional negative space
between the line items
just to separate the items
with something
other than a rule.
And a similar app
structure is maintained
throughout our layouts.
And you can see that here by
the left nav being opened.
Our responsive solutions
combine fixed, fluid,
and sticky elements that should
be able to adapt to the way
that people use their devices.
You can see that here
by the mobile screen.
The density of information
that's being shown
relates to the
amount of information
that people want to interact
with on their phone.
On tablet, we can
add illustrations,
we can add photographs, to make
a more immersive and playful
experience.
And then, when the
screen grows, we
can add intentional
negative space again
to separate content areas.
The toolbar that's
being shown here
is also extremely flexible.
It can rest on a
background, it can
be transparent over
an image, or it
can fit within
any defined space.
Our designs show a lot of
variations in the toolbars
to make them generally
more useful and flexible.
Sometimes, we extend the top bar
just to add a splash of color
to our screens.
We can use cards to
keep text line lengths
at digestible sizes when
the screen gets bigger.
Primary content can be higher in
z depth or closer to the glass.
In this contacts screen, you
can see that a left nav also
might be pinned and
scroll under the toolbar,
while primary content in a card
might scroll over the toolbar.
You can also see
here that what was
full width on a
mobile screen is now
a floating card or a
floating surface on desktop.
You can also see one
of our designers.
In this music
example, we're using
a bottom bar for the player.
We're using large
photographs in the background
and dynamic color choices.
We're also using a
Floating Action Button,
this little blue Play button
in some of the screens
here, just to add a
pop of color to screen.
Bethany's going to talk a
little bit more about that.
There's a lot of
structural nuance
that's happening in this screen.
Our toolbars can have
all types of content
in them, from photographs
to input fields.
And we can use typographic
scale by having dynamic type.
Menus that generate
from toolbars,
they can come above other
elements in z depth.
And this plays into our story
of real materials in real space
that can do magical things.
And not all of our
toolbars are pinned
to the top in a colored bar.
They can be associated
with a surface that's
currently in focus.
So if you imagine this
toolbar here associated
with this list view,
when it scrolls down,
that toolbar might come with it.
So how does all of
this content move?
There's going to be a lot more
details covered in the motion
talk that's happening
later today.
But let's talk a little
bit about scrolling.
This is a common scrolling
pattern that's happening here.
Content moves up, the
app bar scrolls off.
And the status bar
picks up a little bit
of the color of the
application and sticks around,
which is something
new with Material.
Also, when a user
scrolls back here,
the toolbar can come
back at a little bit
of a different pace
than the content.
In this example,
you can see how we
think of the top
toolbar in blocks.
There's one block that contains
the search field and another
that contains tabs.
On scroll, these are
handled independently.
So here, we're pushing
off the top search bar
and keeping the tabs.
And this is dependent on the
context of the application.
You can also see that, on
the slightest downward pull,
the search bar comes back.
This is where things
get really exciting.
We can have
photographs that morph
into colored bars
on our toolbars.
We can have dynamic
UI that removes itself
from the screen
in different ways.
Our typography can
scale and move.
Scrolling and the
way that things move
is very much dependent on
content and the context
and the containers
that hold our content.
So with that in
mind, Dave's going
to talk more about components.
DAVE CHIU: So now that
we've covered Material
and how it's structured,
let's take a closer look
at some of the bits
and pieces that make up
an interface and some
of the best practices
for implementing them.
At a high level, one key
thing you typically want to do
is organize information to
help your users make decisions.
We support the expected forms
of content organization-- lists,
grids, and now, formally, cards.
Lists and grids are familiar
and well understood.
Lists are great for text, and
grids are great for images.
But the question of why
and when to use cards
has been a point of some
uncertainty in the past.
So here's some more
concrete guidelines.
Cards are great for
displaying a set of data
with different content types.
Google now is a perfect
example-- stock quotes,
weather, directions,
World Cup scores--
as a little aside here, any
spontaneous booing or cheering
during our talk will
not be taken personally.
Each card can have a
dramatically different
presentation, so making them
separate pieces of paper
makes sense.
Cards are malleable and
can easily handle data sets
where content varies in
length from item to item.
In comparison, lists and
grids have a natural bias
towards regularity,
making them best
for consistently
structured data.
Each card can contain
a heterogeneous mix
of media, text,
controls, and actions
related to a single subject.
Cards give you the flexibility
to combine and create complex
compositions of content and
actions, such as +1 buttons,
sliders, and comments, in
a way that lists and grids
aren't simply
designed to handle.
But just because
you can use cards
does not mean you
should use them.
When deciding between
lists, grids, or cards,
first ask yourself, how can I
best support my user's goals?
Are they trying to
find a specific thing,
like a photo or a file?
Grids and lists have
a consistent rhythm
and composition that
makes them easy to scan
and well suited for
quick comparison.
In contrast, cards are
harder to scan through
because of their
irregular cadence.
But they are great for browsing
diverse content and layouts.
As these examples show, adding
more pieces of paper, more ink,
and more shadows to the screen
increases noise and distraction
without increasing clarity.
Remember, you can
always split an item
into its own piece of paper
the instant it's needed.
So that's a brief overview of
containers and some guidelines
around when to use each type.
Bethany will now cover more
of the components and best
practices to use when building
Material Design interfaces.
BETHANY FONG: So we looked at
all the standard UI elements,
like buttons, text
fields, and switches,
from a Material
Design perspective
so that they, too,
will help you create
one adaptive design
for your app.
And these goals of
moderating complexity
and of reacting
appropriately extend
into all of our elements.
Our controls are designed to
be consistent with the larger
visual story.
We use simple geometric
shapes to build
more complex, but still
cohesive, components.
And by building
with paper and ink,
our components have an enhanced
ability to react to the user.
For example, as elements
come into focus,
they become alive,
hinting at what's
to come by ebbing and
flowing between the rest
and the pressed state,
through diffusing ink
and traveling
through the z space.
Element states have
been simplified to help
as you design
across form factors.
All of the element
states are coordinated
so that the same element
will function correctly
in a design that is being used
with different input methods.
You can see that each
input method works nicely
with the others without having
to duplicate your control
states.
And as you create custom
controls for your own app,
you may want to follow a
similar approach for quicker
adaptability.
I'm going to talk in more
detail about buttons.
There are three
styles of buttons,
and each is appropriate for
different circumstances.
The Floating Action
Button is known
by its shorthand, the FAB.
The FAB is the newest
and has the most unique
characteristics, while the
others are more familiar.
Both the FAB and
the raised buttons
are made of paper
in Material Design,
and the flat button
is made of ink.
This pyramid illustrates
the frequency
of use of different
button styles.
The FAB is the strongest
in the visual hierarchy
and is most rarely used.
It's special.
The raised button is used more
commonly, but still sparingly.
It's quite visible, but
because it doesn't float
means it doesn't respond to z
space changes in the same way
that the FAB does.
And finally, there
is the flat button,
a very commonly used control.
So I heard in the
session yesterday there's
a really good question
that was, basically,
what are all the
circles on the screen?
And here it is.
It's the FAB.
So it represents the single
hallmark action for a screen.
It's a tool for you to call
out the key parts of your app's
product story.
It should be used
for actions that
are strongly
characteristic of your app.
Pausing or resuming
playback tells me
that this is a music app.
Or driving directions tells
me that this is a maps app.
Not every screen
should use a FAB,
because not every screen has
an action with this importance.
It doesn't really have
the right type of data.
It's a natural cue for telling
users what to do next, also.
So in user research, we found
that users understood it
as a way-finding tool.
Research shows that, when
faced with an onslaught
of unfamiliar screens, as many
users do on a regular basis,
like when they install your
app for the first time,
they started using
the FAB to navigate.
And users discovered
that it was really
useful as a signpost
of what's important.
And here, the FAB is
being used in a variety
of different types of apps.
You can see how it highlights a
hallmark action for each app--
compose for a messaging app,
add files for a storage app,
and so on.
And you've probably
noticed that it
can be placed around the screen.
And we have a few
recommended places
that work pretty well, like in
the lower right-hand corner.
The FAB is also
the first element
that is allowed
to straddle a seam
or allowed the hang
over a paper edge,
such as in the
screen for people.
And also note that there's
only one FAB per screen.
There should never be multiple
on screen at one time,
as that confuses our
visual hierarchical goal.
You can use your app's
accent color for your FAB.
Just make sure that you
retain adequate contrast
from the background.
Because the FAB
is character-ful,
it's generally a
positive action,
like create, favorite, share,
navigate, explore, and so on.
And unless it's truly
the hallmark of an app,
FAB shouldn't be destructive
actions, like archive or trash.
They also shouldn't
be unspecific
or alerts, limited actions
like cutting and pasting text,
or stuff that should
really been in a toolbar,
like changing the volume.
Basically, the
function should be
an action that makes
your user feel really
positive about using
the FAB and never
worried it's going to
do something wrong.
So it's not just a round button.
It has some
transformative properties
that you'll be able
to use to help ease
your users from
screen to screen.
It can expand, morph, and react.
The FAB can replace
itself with a sequence
of more specific of actions.
This helps surface a set that
don't really belong at the top,
but are still important.
And you can design them to
be contextual to your users.
Imagine a user tapping the
FAB and their favorite people
expanding out as contacts.
And these do need to be tightly
related actions, as well
as ones which can be understood
through the simple initial
icon.
So for example, if an add FAB
hides the search function,
users won't naturally think
to look there for search.
And lastly, don't turn your
FAB into an action overflow.
Those still belong
in the app bar.
So because the FAB is
made of floating paper,
it can morph into
a new surface that
allows for richer interactions.
For example, you
can have a new Post
FAB, which enlarges directly
into a composition field
or into an open
camera viewfinder.
It's not just a fancy
or dropdown menu.
You're making your hero
action even more heroic
and reinforcing
the sense that this
is a core usage of your app.
As you recall, FABs
can be positioned
along steps or seams of paper.
And as that paper moves, the FAB
can transfer its anchor point.
Reactions can be
simple as shifting
a FAB's position in response
to other paper moving,
like in Zach's example.
Or as a user
scrolls down a page,
the FAB can hop locations from
scene to scene or even off
to a floating
position so that users
don't lose sight of that
important FAB function.
So with that, you
should have a picture
of what the new Material
Design elements are like
and what the FAB
can do for your app.
RICH FULCHER: So
we've covered kind
of the basics of
Material Design, how
the materials behave.
We've talked about layout,
we've talked about structure,
we highlighted a couple
of key components.
But as developers and designers
who already have apps,
the question on your mind
is probably, what's next?
How do I take these
Material Design principles,
this new system, and
apply it to my apps?
The good news is we
haven't thrown out
anything you already know.
So all of the components
that you're used to using,
they're still there.
They're still supported.
We've given them a
little bit of a refresh
to make them more
reactive, more alive.
But they're still there, and
you can still count on them.
As announced yesterday, there is
a preview release of our new UI
guidelines available at
www.google.com/design.
And this covers all of
the standard components
that we didn't address
today that haven't changed.
So you can see all
of those elements.
You can get all the
updated guidance on those.
It's also packed with examples.
So you may see in those
examples something that
inspires you to think about
the design of your app
or part of your app in a
slightly different way.
Here's a screenshot from
the spec covering the layout
chapter, just showing
a few wire frames.
And it clearly shows the
application of the 8-DIP grid
that Zach talked about.
And you can see some of
the key lines called out.
All of these guides have
been responsibly designed
so that they'll work well on
desktop, on tablet, on phone.
You can check them
on any of the devices
that you're designing for.
I wouldn't read them on
your new fancy Android Wear.
But everything else
we've got covered.
So this site will
continue to evolve
as our frameworks update.
There are also a lot of
really helpful resources,
particularly for interaction
designers, on this site.
So we offer a bunch
of layout templates
for the standard views.
We have sticker sheets of
all of the component types.
And if you're thinking
Android, they're
in light and dark
theme available there.
And then there are also color
palettes, icon sets, advice
or animation, lots and
lots of content there.
But we'd like to leave
you with a challenge.
And that is to
think about not just
how you can make your app more
attractive, more delightful
by applying Material
Design to it.
But how can you use these
principles to actually make
your app easier to use?
And one way to start on that is
to question some of the design
decisions you may
have already made.
So let's start with the
biggest one, the question of,
how do I structure
my application?
We talked about
structuring based
on hierarchy in this talk.
But another way of
thinking about it
might be to structure
based on motion,
planning for all the
different surfaces
that you want to have moving
between the different views
within your application.
And what are those elements
that should be lifted up,
that are important, that want
to get that signature treatment?
Motion provides
meaning to the user.
It is a form of feedback which
focuses the user's attention.
And it builds a
sense of continuity
between different states
within your application.
So relatedly, how do
you move to a model that
is-- the old model
we've been building in
is this kind of screen,
screen, screen style
of design, where I start
at the top of my app,
and then I build all
the intermediary screens
till I get to the
bottom of the app.
And we just kind of realize
those one at a time.
We can do something
much more fluid now.
We can use transitions to give
the user the sense that they
can do more work in fewer
places within the app
by just transforming the
context slightly for them.
So we can use animation
to guide the user here,
rather than just dropping them
into some new context where
they have to reorient
themselves after they've
landed from the teleport.
You can guide them
more easily, build up
more of that sense of
direction and connection
between these
different conditions.
And think about what
you would do for the FAB
if it's appropriate
for your screen.
What is that hallmark
application or that hallmark
action that you'd
want affiliated
with your application?
Or think of it this
way-- what's that action
that you want to clearly show
in the screenshot promoting
your app that shows up in the
detail page of a store listing?
What's the thing anybody
looking at that should take away
and say, oh, this app does this?
And in general, how can you
lean into the frameworks more?
Are there things that
you're doing currently
in a custom way
that no longer need
to be custom, that can
take advantage of some
of the new APIs
that are present?
Can you make your code
base faster, smaller,
easier to maintain by relying
on the framework more?
There are three more
excellent sessions today
covering different aspects
of Material Design.
There's one starting
at the top of the hour.
And then, later today, we
have sessions specifically
on visual design and
on motion design.
We also have the Sandbox space.
If you've come by there, you've
seen the new UI guidelines
projected on giant
touch screens.
We'll have a couple of
small, short talks there.
I'll give a talk at 2:00
on a little bit more detail
about using paper and
ink and how those work.
But all of the designers
here, as well as others,
will be in that space.
It's a really great opportunity
to ask any questions you might
have and just come
by and say hi.
We're happy to meet you.
And with that, thank you
very much for your interest
and for your attention today.
[APPLAUSE]
And we'll happily
take a few questions
in the time that remains.
MALE SPEAKER: Hello,
I'm [? Akeel ?]
from the University of Maryland.
And I just had a question
about the navigation drawer.
What were the reasons behind
moving the hamburger icon
from halfway beyond the
edge to into the screen?
RICH FULCHER: OK.
I think this question maybe
relates most to Android.
So formerly, in Android, you'd
have the application icon
and then a hint of the drawer
indicator icon beside it.
Part of Material has moved
away from using the app icon
as the visual identifier
of where you are.
And we tried to encourage
developers to express the app's
identity more through
those standards of color
and typography and treatment
to make each view more
character-ful and more
immediately recognizable.
So as we moved away from
using the application icon,
we want to give a
full width affordance
in that space for
opening the drawer.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
RICH FULCHER: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi.
This is essentially paper, but
I haven't seen any folding.
Is there any specific
reason for that?
DAVE CHIU: So one
of the things I
talked about was this
notion of perceived z depth.
And so, when you're
handling a phone,
you have a sense
of the thickness
of that between the glass
and the back of the phone.
So we want to
preserve the notion
that there is a finite
amount of space to use.
And so, if you start
folding things,
then that would sort
of break the plane.
That's something potentially
you could explore maybe
on deeper z depth environments,
like televisions, when
you start thinking
about three dimensions.
But for now, we're really
focusing on keeping things
in a single z position and sort
of moving things laterally.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, makes sense.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi.
So the I mainly
was wanting to ask
about, for backwards
compatibility, to getting
these new patterns into as far
back as, like, Gingerbread.
Is that possible?
And also, for low-end devices
with all these new animations,
what are things that-- is it
just better not to use those?
Or what are good guidelines?
RICH FULCHER: Sure.
I think my take on
the best practice
is you want to kind of
design for Material Design,
first and foremost.
We've found that the translation
exercise of taking something
that's designed for Material and
kind of simplifying it downward
has been a reasonably
straightforward one.
I mean, most of the same
elements are still there.
You still have things like
action bars and toolbars.
You can make them
less transformative
as the design goes down
to earlier versions.
And some of these
changes will actually
be supported through
Support Library, as well.
So I think you just start
with the highest end,
you simplify to pare
it down, and then
you still have a design
that feels very coherent.
Material has a unique
theme on Androids.
You can target that theme
and build against it.
And you can kind of see what
happens on that right away.
The second part of your
question was-- sorry,
just remind me quickly.
MALE SPEAKER: Low-end devices.
RICH FULCHER:
Low-end devices, yes.
So the animation
framework will actually
be aware of the capabilities.
It will basically shorten or
remove animations in some cases
to make sure that,
instead of just getting
a very junky or
stuttery animation,
you just sometimes get a clean
cut or cross-fade instead
of a more elaborate one.
So it's not as full
of an experience,
but it still feels kind of
complete for that device.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, thanks.
RICH FULCHER: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi.
I have the
skeuomorphism question.
I'm wondering how
that went internally.
And do you guys
consider the skeuomorph?
DAVE CHIU: So skeuomorphism.
So that's the notion
of introducing
kind of ornament and unnecessary
elements into design.
And I would say
that, in this case,
we're trying to use
paper as an inspiration.
It's an interesting question,
because I guess the most amount
of skeuomorphism that
you could potentially
call skeuomorphism is,
effectively, shadowing,
because, effectively, they're
just pieces of paper that
are moving about.
There's no additional
ornament beyond it's
a blank piece of paper
that you're adding ink to.
The idea there is
that we're trying
to add additional affordances
so people can more intelligently
understand what's going on.
Conversations have
given the design
world talk about flat
design and post flat design.
Arguably, this is kind of post
flat design, because we're
trying to take the direction
of flat design, which
is the answer or response
to skeuomorphism-- that's
one extreme end of the
spectrum-- we're trying to pull
it back and say,
we do kind of need
to introduce a little bit more
affordance here and give users
guidance as to how
things work, how
they relate to each
other, what to expect.
ZACH GIBSON: Yeah.
Just to add to
that, I think we're
at a place that's kind
of in between the flat
and skeuomorphism.
A lot of our stuff is
flat on first appearance,
but it's tangible
and you can touch it.
And when you do touch
it and interact with it,
it feels real.
And I think that that's
a kind of place that's
in between pure, flat design
and skeuomorphic stuff.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
Thank you.
ZACH GIBSON: Yeah, sure.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi.
You'll have to forgive me
if this is a basic design
question, because
I'm a developer.
But you mentioned that it's
important to have the FAB's
primary color work well with
the image content behind it.
I'm just wondering if
there is sort of a way
that you determine what
that is dynamically
based on the content.
And if so, is that available
in Polymer and Android?
RICH FULCHER: Yeah.
So the library is
called Palette.
It is a way of extracting
the dominant color
value from an image
and then using
that to select the complimentary
color that's appropriate.
I think there are
a few cases where
the FAB would want to do that.
I think the FAB in
particular often
wants to be a known, fixed
color for easy identifiability
within your app.
That said, there are
a couple of contexts
where it makes sense to do that.
But it is supported.
And Palette is the
name of that library.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
RICH FULCHER: Sure.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi.
FAB definitely stands
out for me in this talk.
And I think through
the whole conference,
designing for your
cross platform is
one of the main
themes this year.
So I'm just wondering,
any thoughts
on how to apply FAB in TV
space, like in a TV UI?
Because for most
of TV, the remote
doesn't have a touch screen,
and it still operates on D-pad.
So I'm just wondering,
any thoughts on that?
BETHANY FONG: Yeah.
So the FAB is a raised button
which still has a focus state.
And I know that a
lot of our TV UI
relies on moving the focus
state around the screen.
And a lot of our
apps on Android TV,
we've actually used the FAB
very successfully using focus
to pull it out.
So it still works.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, thanks.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi.
My question is kind of related.
So I love what you've
done to, I guess,
facilitate design
cross-platform.
So I'm wondering, if you're
working on a product that
is still primarily desktop--
is still kind of becoming
responsive, but is still
desktop-- do you feel like some
of these things, like the new
animations or the metaphors
of paper and ink, is that still
appropriate for a primarily
desktop application?
Or does it require
interaction via touch?
ZACH GIBSON: Yeah, I think
it's still appropriate.
A lot of the Polymer stuff
that we've been working on
implements some of these
touch ripples and animations.
And you can kind of get
some of that stuff for free
by using Polymer
elements in desktop.
But yeah, I think it
totally still applies.
On mobile, there's
no hover states.
And there's definitely
differences.
And I think we're trying to
respect those differences
in the different form factors.
But just from a
structural standpoint,
keeping all of the
same stuff around
is how we're keeping
consistent across form factors.
DAVE CHIU: And as Bethany and
I have both sort of discussed,
the notion of the FAB
transforming and also
just paper hierarchy,
some of those things
still apply to desktop.
So you can start
talking about how
the FAB transforms
a to-do paper.
And that helps cue
users that there's
a new activity or a new action
being-- when you're composing
a new email or
note or something,
that can turn into a new
piece of paper and helps
give them some sense
of relationship
with that new
surface, with the work
that they've been
previously doing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Have
you found that users,
that their relationship
with the mouse in the screen
is kind of similar
with their relationship
to just clicking on the screen?
Have you kind of explored that?
RICH FULCHER: There's
a bit more difference.
I don't think any of us
are too close to that work
specifically.
But I know from the
development of the pixel
that users sometimes
move between those modes
of engagement.
Like when a touchscreen
is available,
that's appropriate
for some lighter
browsing-oriented activities.
But the more precise targeting
and more work active,
I'm alternating between
keyboard and mouse,
they tend to bias
towards that affordance.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
Thank you.
RICH FULCHER: Sure.
All right.
Well, thank you all again.
DAVE CHIU: Thank you.
ZACH GIBSON: Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]